aux côtés de mettre ce banc martine
aubert la soeur de sylvie tué en 86
l'une et l'autre refuse que le dossier
soit purement et simplement refermer
suis pas d'accord toutes les pistes
n'ont pas été exploitées il reste
beaucoup de pistes web alors qu'ils
n'ont pas été du moins terminer hors de
question qu'ils ferment donc on va se
battre
je n'ai pas laissé faire remettre ce
banc corinne herrmann l'association
christelle bon bah on n'a pas lâché on a
sera pas voilà les enquête n'avance plus
il n'y a plus de moyens miz dessus et
aujourd'hui on nous dit pour sylvie
aubert et bien il faut rendre un non
lieu il n'y a rien à chercher il n'y a
rien à trouver
je vous rappelle quand même qu'à auxerre
après la sphère des disparues de l'yonne
et bien il y avait plus d'eau au total
onze meurtres de jeunes femmes qui
n'avaient pas été élucidée par le
travail qui a été réalisé il n'y en a
plus qu'un aujourd'hui donc être
pourquoi ce qui est une vérité à auxerre
ne serait pas une vérité à dijon la
décision de la chambre d'instruction de
la cour d'appel sera connu le 15 mai
mais cette volonté de la justice de
clore les vieux dossiers
l'association christelle s'en
inquiétaient depuis un moment déjà
on a toujours dit dans la hantise de
rare qu'un dossier peut être fermé ils
ont ensuite une décision d'un juge
d'instruction
donc c'est pour ça il faut toujours
aller travailler en continu et c'est
pour ça disons qu'on assiste toujours
open aux avocats pour que disons le
nécessaire soit fait dans l'ensemble des
dossiers on encore sept dossiers
les sept autres dossiers disons en
dehors de miley et puis de batteries
doivent être travaillés en continuité en
parallèle c'était en octobre dernier
lors du procès en appel de pascal jardin
condamné pour le meurtre de christelle
blétry en 96 chacun voulait alors croire
que cette seconde affaire résolue à les
accentuer la pression sur la justice
il n'y a pas de raison que les autres
familles n'est pas non plus une réponse
il est essentiel que les magistrats qui
ont en charge ces dossiers et magistrats
de la région et puis elle magistrat plus
généralement sache qu'on peut sortir des
dossiers très anciens qu'on peut arriver
à des condamnations
après sylvie aubert d'autres dossiers
seront sans doute sur la sellette
une perspective que l'association
christelle ressent comme une véritable
gifle